I
okay so welcome everybody so to simplify
my name is Pedro Cardoso and I'm the
text analytics director at synthase co
which means basically I'm responsible
for all that is related to natural
language processing at the company so
I'm going to talk about the parallel
processing using Python and gierman
simply because everything we do in
regarding NLP is an imp I turn and we
needed to distribute it for other people
to you see the services a very brief
explanation of what's going to happen so
i'll start by explaining a little bit
the need so what we wanted to do what we
had in our hands i'll go through a few
possibilities just right it's very
briefly show what exists otherwise ten
gierman which is a job queue system and
i'll finally use gierman with the python
so like a small example of how do you
put the whole thing together I'm not
trying to make something like important
production style but it's just something
some simple to do so starting with the
neat thing first of all like so what is
synthase oh we are a social listening
tool that we also do collaboration and
engagement but in short it means that we
collect through crawlers everything that
is happening on the social media beat my
own Facebook Twitter obviously everybody
knows but also all the blogs all the
forums we go to newspaper also like so
the more traditional media we go to
pages of people you know a lot of
companies already have their own blogs
and all the comments that are made on on
this blog also we do our data coverage
like is basically we get millions of
verbotene per day and collect everybody
can understand what is the velveteen so
that will be mentioning it over and over
for a suburban team is the document is
the piece of information usually text
but it can be like a very short one like
a preacher or can be very long one like
a blog post we do like coverage on 220
countries with around 80 languages
and we are I'm going to focus mostly on
the data text analytics so
classification by visualization and this
is what we are aiming to so to
understand a little bit more what we
were trying what we try to do so we have
a dashboard which is basically the
product so it's a dashboard that will
put in a concise way all the information
that was collected regarding you so our
customers are a big brand and they want
to know what people say about them in
the public media you want to know if a
new product people say very good things
if they say terrible stuff if it's for
example imagine you just release a new
car and no one to know if people like
the design if people don't like the
design if they like the technical specs
if this is too expensive whatever so
what you want to do is like first of all
you want to gather all this data we are
going to classify the data and we want
also to visualize it so we have like two
simple examples the first one the
sentiment per topic so here you can
already see for example we start by
doing sentiment analysis on the
messengers by telling okay is it
positive is it negative people say good
or bad things we can also classify back
topics are they talking about the
specific cities of product are you
talking about the price are you talking
about the specific problem and we can
basically in a concise way show this to
the customer we can also understand more
like do like some kind of word clouds
with more information attached so you
can see more or less if these words are
used in the positive context so like
previous was basically positive to Angus
people didn't like it probably so this
is what we want to achieve we want to
process this million of bourbon teens
that arrive every day and just so that
you have an idea we have close to 20
between 20 and 40 million per day
depends on the day quietly usually
weekends are lower and we want to
analyze all this data and we want to put
it in the visible way for our problems
so that we are all understand what's
going on here I am NOT talking about all
the models were created i'm specifying
how we use them in deployment so how we
deploy did it and if you're interested
actually cannot talk about later one but
basically we do everything in Python
it's mostly SQ learn which
other tools available there's one ltk
but we don't really use that one so what
we need for our processing first of all
a new verbotene arrives so we need to
process right now first thing is to
detect the language was this written in
in German in English in Spanish in
Japanese whatever once we have that we
are going to do something which is
basically the same for everybody so like
sentiment analysis and sentimentality
and the posi- finally will restore it
and index it so that it can be used in
the tooth but he's not related here so
now we have a new customer when he comes
and he wants to have like his new
dashboard he wants to understand what
people say about them so he will have
its own configuration and this becomes
more particularly for a customer because
a dashboard can be on auto industry can
be on health products perfumes it can be
on food products like why is my cat food
killing my cat for example and now we
are going to do like noise filtering so
like we are going to first of all he
will do this by setting up kind of the
search queries and the first things like
there will always be a lot of noise if
you can think of for example around
Orange it's a it's a brand its telecom
in you in UK and in France but it's also
the fruit so that can create a lot of
noise so we can use the machine learning
to remove all these non-pertinent
messages and then we do topic
classification for also so self I
already talking about which particular
set of features of the product or
whatever so this is what we need to do
and again this do you need to do it for
a lot of data and it's not one simple
source of data so we have all these
processes that are demanding to have
this lated process classified it finally
also it like the request from
visualization so this one's we get it
into the product and in real time we
need to visualize it so we need to grab
the accumulated data that you want to
see after filtered and we are going to
visualize it we need to somehow process
we can actually say basically what's the
correlation between the words so said ok
these words are mostly used
some context it means something here so
that basically the customer can navigate
the data in the more efficient way so as
I was mentioning we have our crawlings
and collections which are basically a
set of lots of programs running all of
them want to ask for the classification
we have our feeders adding data to the
dashboards they also want to classify
data and this is our objective so what
we're going to do is up here these
services again let's hope this is like
parallel but I mean this is just to
remember everybody like doing an LP in
general it's embarrassingly parallel
meaning we have a lot of data to process
but each one is processed independently
we don't care for what's the combination
it's not like we are creating a model
that has a lot of data we need to have
like multiple processes accessing shared
memory you know it's simple as that I
mean each one is by himself they have a
lot of requests each request we
processed one by one and you get the
results but there's one specific point
which is our processes cannot be spawned
like easily because we need to load a
lot of data so when you think of a
classifier object you need to load the
models you need to load dictionaries and
whatever else is required for the system
and this can to certain sometimes you
can reach like half a Giga easily so
it's not something that you just load
from a hard drive and you do a
classification off a few sets and you go
down and you start again 'ok the new set
so possibilities I mean this is like
what we could have done otherwise but we
didn't like we could just go and do
ourselves our multi-process classes we
could just do a RPC or a job queues and
so starting with the multi-process class
i mean the basic one is you know just
create a pool object you say like I have
like ten processes running in parallel
to process my data as it comes and you
create this very simple code I mean it's
just simple code at anybody can do it in
a few seconds few minutes by basically
crater pool you
and the data synchronously to by the
pool you wait until it's ready when it's
ready to get the result or you can
basically a map basically does like ever
least it will process the whole list one
by one and you get the results of
everything once all is done so the first
stop is synchronously the lower part is
synchronous but of course I mean first
of all this there's no persistent data
so if you do it just like that you're
going to have to load half a gig every
time you have one data to to load so if
you have like you know I can a message
of urban teen of one kilo beat and you
leave half a Giga also its single
machine as it is and I mean it's not
really a service image to do a service
into the lot more and the objective was
not to do something from the ground of
course I mean if you said there's no
persistent data in the process you can
actually somehow make it you could you
can initialize in the pool you can
initialize the each process and you
define a global class where you put like
your classifier and afterwards in the
actual map function that will be calling
with the pool you have this already
loaded so this is like a global will
have always available object so somehow
you can do it but of course and if you
want to do this you are not going to do
it like everything from the ground you
can just use a parallel Python you can
use a job lib there are a lot of
possibilities and those already allow
you to like spawn among several machines
but again I mean this is not what I want
to do this is very useful when you are
actually creating your model and
personally I use quite a lot the pools
just to gather the data so and I have a
lot of data together I collect on the
diet I need to process somehow
everything is like parallel so it's
simple to do but not the objective here
another idea is remote procedure call or
RPC is just so that have an idea how
many people know of this can raise your
arm okay outside twenty percent so I
mean remote procedure call is something
like you have your object in a machine
and you want to expose its methods to
everybody to anybody so you create a
rapper
around your class who are on your object
and through a service it will basically
connect so any other process can create
a proxy object that will emulate all the
metals from this other object which is
somewhere in the different machine or a
different process and you can call it as
if it was local so you you just ask for
the method if you'll connect to your
through the proxy to the service and
return to the results there are protocol
buffers and trees which are from google
and facebook if i don't not mistaken and
they are nice i mean they basically you
actually need to define the API I mean
it's not automatic things don't just
show up it's for multi programming
languages and so on but so it's more
like it's just a protocol but if you
need to build a lot of things we have
also pyro for and this one I've used
quite a lot it's basically out of the
box so it will understand the methods it
will basically expose them right away it
works quite okay but again this is not
what we wanted to do because you wanted
to have something more root not flexible
lets do Q or I can want something more
flexible that we would not would not
don't want to mix around with like name
servers because if you want to connect
to the rapper like to the proc you need
to know where it is so true you need
need to go look for it you need to have
like an Amy service you need to to
search I mean it's not something that
you can easily do so we went for looking
for job queue systems which is basically
what we are focusing on here and
basically a job queue system is composed
of three main components components you
have the client that wants something to
be done you have the worker that is the
process that will run your desk and you
have the server which is basically the
queue the least a job is what we want to
be done and the main possibilities with
the pie I mean there's two main systems
of pythons accelerate and gierman celery
basically just a communication protocol
with a Lib libraries in any
more like a communication it uses in the
back bonus headies or think there's a
RabbitMQ so you can choose one of them
it's independent you basically have your
API for the client and the server that
will communicate through a third party
application gearman is the actual server
then you have api's that will basically
use we used to communicate with the
server itself and its server it's going
to manage the priorities the time out
the handling of all the clients and
servers and workers so how we use this
with Python come in very simple example
so first of all what is exactly here man
so this is an image that I just took
from their website it's basically fault
tolerance tolerance so it's multi-server
meaning we have two job servers they can
be in different machines if one goes
down it's bigger because the server went
down word because network went down the
other one continues you have multiple
workers they can be connected to one
server or they can be connected to
multiple servers so if they are in a
different machine and the server goes
down they will notice so they will keep
working with the remaining server your
clients also they will connect to the
servers but if you put a load balancer
it's all good so if one server goes down
you basically still have all the clients
going to the remaining one and
everything keeps you running the only
problem is that it's a queue system so
you will have probably jobs in a queue
when the system goes down but there are
also ways of somehow to cash this to
store it so that if once the server
comes back up your tasks are will be
reloaded and we can just continue or the
simple stories like the client dies the
see that the server died you just
connect to the next one and ask again
it's distributed there's an API for
monitoring and now be coming back to
this at the end and the best part of it
is that it's multiple programming
languages API so we have Titan PHP yes
Java Sea I mean a lot of them and this
was important for us because all the NLP
infrastructure it's done on Python but
everything else is not like they all
basically running java PA
should be some small see stuff so
everything else is in any other language
and what we wanted to do is like okay
they are you the process is in place we
cannot just go and plug something in the
middle that will not work well we need
to have something here serving and the
existing code needs to start asking this
application so we need to start having
like we now are going to offer like
sentiment analysis we want to add this
to the system we cannot just put
something in the media that will disturb
the whole crawling system we need to
have it outside so going to a very
simple example like I'm going to work
like a just explain like how would you
do for language classification so we
were having like client which requires
like the worker to do language ID and we
will see also how do we monitor and what
you can do with monetization so starting
with the communication part this is how
it's handled by the server so the first
thing you can do is like you can want to
create like a the worker and the client
you call it very simple I don't know if
you guys can actually what look it's
quite small I don't know if it's visible
to everybody but sorry for it so the
first thing you do is like you create a
worker and a client if you like from
each side but how do they communicate so
the data communication process is in
binary everything that goes through the
server is binary from the server point
of view I mean you can basically throw
anything you want so if you can throw
anything you want why not Jason so it's
simpler you don't need to be converting
stuff you don't need to create weird
protocols you just convert it and you
can do it simply you extend the class
that encoder you define the method to
encode you define the method to decode
and you have something that will
basically do Jason and how do you use
this you create your own worker class
you say that the data encoder system is
my new class and you just create a new
worker and now what you have is that
your worker will not receive binary data
but you'll received already Jason
decoded data because when it when it
gets here we have the string so that we
have our backs
and we just returned it into an object a
simple object of course mini suggestion
so usually dictionary that's usually the
best way to go around so it's an your
parameters in the dictionary of course I
mean if it can be whatever and if
everybody's working with Python just
pickle it's the simplest way and now you
can basically send a Python object
around so if you're applying it wants to
process stuff you sent the Python object
and you don't even care of doing all the
pickling and and pickling because it
will be done through the API so the
worker we start by defining what to
worker needs to do in our guys we want
to do language classification so what we
are going to do here we create our
language heidi classifier object which
is basically i mean just like the model
to lambda phi and we are going to
identify the methods in this case more
active functions like what is actually
done so we receive the data we get our
object so here is true dictionary since
we have like two other languages we do
Jason for communication so we grabbed
from a dictionary already in the
dictionary you get the text we
classified and we send back a new
dictionary with the probability of being
a specific language and the language
that was found we can also have multiple
in the same worker can have actually
have multiple services so for example
let's say I want to do the same but i
don't need the text you just give me the
idea of the document and i will myself
look into the database i will collect
the text and I will do everything else
the same and i'll send you the results
so this is can be in the case for
example i mean in the interface when
they are processing stuff they want me
to show the data they don't really care
about collecting the data themselves
they want to say this is the data you
are going to collect go check on the
database what it what it is process it
and give you the results so you can
actually have multiple services in the
same worker of course what it will be
running one at a time it won't be like
multi-process whatever so each worker
will run one or the other and then we
can actually create the worker so again
I just use the same
I set the name I set the tasks and I put
it into an infinite loop running now I
have my worker or I have two or three
meaning the same code you can launch it
as many times as you want and if you
need 20 workers you grab the same code
you just launch it 20 times there will
be 20 processes running your in your
machine and they will be independent
from each other just one point here as
you can see i actually use the list it's
always a list in any case so meaning if
there's more than one server it will
connect remote to the all the servers
and we're pulling the service to know
where is the data and this is important
for us because what we have is we have
at least in two machines and there will
be a set of workers that will be
specific to a machine so they will only
be running on that machine and there
will be another set of workers that will
be looking at the two machines at the
two servers so that the kind of to
balance because I mean all that is not
equal a tweet will be much faster to
process then a big blog so we cannot
really control control that into in load
balancing so I mean there will be this
extra service just to to catch up when
one is getting delayed from the client
side so the client side is like I'm
going it's an example like running a
synchronously so the first thing you do
you just create your client this is a
different way of doing so if you can you
can just basically create a client from
with the basic class and just define the
data encoder attribute to your Jason
decoder and it works anyway so it's the
same way you don't need to actually go
and create a whole new class just to
define a different data encoder and then
what you want to do is that you want to
send your job to get the results so you
do a submission you tell it what's the
task you create your data so he just put
your dictionary you tell it a priority
and you say wait until completely false
so it will just run away I mean it won't
it will not be waiting for the results
you can actually send multiple ones and
then you can just put them all in a list
and you just wait to see when it's
completed you just put like a simple
check out and you can go through your
list it right
see which ones are complete so if it's
complete you get the result it will be
again the result already it's not the
adjacent and formatting the longer is
already or claw your objects another
dictionary of course in its time out you
just do like you know like create a
warning do whatever you need to do in
this case getting back then to the
management this is something also which
is very interesting for us which was
what like we have our server but we want
to know what's going on I mean for
multiple purposes so what you can do is
that you could you go shouldn't several
is just to serve itself you create like
a Gilman admin client and you do get
status and what it will return for each
of those tasks that we've seen so like
in my worker example I had two tasks it
will return as status it will tell me
that i actually have eight workers which
are inactive they're just chillin there
this is just bogus data it will tell me
how many actually are running so
processing data it will tell me the clap
the task name and it will tell me how
many I have in my queue having running
workers like eight and that in a queue
is possible because again remember that
a worker can have multiple tasks but if
you'll only be performing one at a time
so if you have like maybe they are like
idle to this specific task because
they're processing the other task so
this is totally possible but what can we
see from this data we can see like
what's the queue size for example and
that's important because you can see we
can monitor it first of all so if you
have your like you know tactic graphs
and you see that your queue is all is
new Jo it's because you probably did not
have enough server the workers so what
you can do I mean one simple things
actually can even one drink to that is
always kind of probing the the service
and if you see that your clap your queue
is getting too big you basically you can
just spawn more workers and it will
eventually come down you can do
preemptively do this I mean if you
analyze your data and you
that specific times of today things
increase like every day in the morning
people love to tweet is the first thing
they do probably around the toilet there
you go I get my tweets I retweet I do
whatever so your data will increase you
can predict these and two hours before
just lunch all your workers and once
when the flux of later come you're ready
but you can also if for example there
was a crisis so everybody started
suddenly to talk of something when there
was the airplane that crashed I mean
everybody just started to eat it like
started to comment it's something that
happens so what you do like you visually
monitor it when things go up you launch
more workers and then this is also good
because you can see how many our workers
are active and this can be for example
to see if for example something crash I
mean if you know or you expect to have
ten workers and suddenly your status
tells you that we only have like five
workers something went wrong either
because like one of the servers went
down they miss the connection or there
was a bug in your code so you can
basically also monitor through this way
and this is basically it for the
presentation I don't know if you guys
have any question now just so that if
somebody's interested we are hiring also
like specifically for front and back-end
developers if you are interested you can
just talk with me later on or just
simply suggest to go to the website see
the options in ship them send the email
so questions yes I have a question about
their ability of gierman and how how it
handles consistency how about it handles
the consistency of the queue because
it's distributed they are always
independent so each server Q will be
independent they don't really share
among them so what happens is that when
your client you can actually in the
client can give one or two servers the
simplest ways to give once
server that is a load balancer if you
don't stay connected so if you don't if
you choose something that you connect
you send the request and wait for the
answer you just put load down so so it
happens basically load balancer will
balance between both and then in the
worker in the workers side if you are
connected to multiple ones they will
somehow balance so you never really have
like a huge discrepancy we never really
saw huge difference of cubes this
somehow and that ball is balancing
themselves have you used this in
combination with a distributed file
system distributed glasser file system
so i cannot distributed file system ah
no so I mean that's something else this
is just to process so this is like think
of this as a web service without being a
web service so it's like it's a service
its independent and I don't care or know
whether that is coming from just connect
so you ship the data the client ships
the data together with the request yes
it depends i mean in my example for the
the worker like I had one I don't I only
receive the ID so in this case because I
mean if the client goes to the device
collected either send it to me and then
just refuse results I mean this all back
and forth the data maybe is not very
optimal so you can just submit the ID
and I will be the one collecting but
from the side I mean I will just use
like you know like a database access
object or HDFS access object and I just
access it so I mean I don't know if that
answers your question or not yeah this
do you know how many people do use a
similar setup together with a
distributed file system I tried to
remember where i read something i think
was some music distribution system on
spotify and they were using it but for a
logging system so they had a worker that
was a logging system that instead of
directly sending to today gfs file or to
database
they were sent they were sending it to a
co-worker so that and then it would be
the worker stalking storing all the log
messages okay so weren't trying to get
at this can gaming system do something
with the data locality with with data
locality I see like a like you know i
canna dupe system that basically knows
that is not himself no I mean if you
want to do that you know in this case
for example what they had is like the
worker can be anywhere so if you're
going to have a worker that logs data
you're going to put maybe this worker on
the logging data database so this is the
system that's going to store the data so
we put the worker where it's being
stored so that all the day it was that
but then the client would have to know
that the client doesn't care the client
sends it to the worker and I mean any if
if you're logging everybody sending log
files from everywhere and then it's it
centralizes but if you want to do just I
mean this is not in a dupe system so
basically the the data needs to come
from somewhere so me it's not if you
want to do what I need for example for
us what a loop system can are useful for
to prepare the data so if you have this
amount of data that you want to somehow
process it treated and collected it so
that you can create your model dare you
using a dupe this is once you already
have the thing and it's in deployment so
as you for example while we are crawling
the debt is not even in a database it's
just going to lower system like our
process system so so there's no place to
go for that I mean if you want to like
use multiprocessing parallel processing
with care where they just go directly to
some kind of a loop system or a sparkle
okay thanks for other questions yes
have you or do you know of applications
where gear man has been used in multiple
OS platforms or machines which have
different operating system I'm sorry a
hue very badly his gear is it possible
to use gear man with machine running
windows and other machine running you
linux with machine learning what so so
can you give different machines one of
which is something windows and different
operating ah yeah you can so each worker
basically has for us like we have so I
don't know if everybody enjoys like if
you can have like in different machines
different services so each worker I mean
for each service with language
classification top classification
automatic sentiment analysis we have for
each service we have a different worker
like a specific worker then you can
decide by ourselves if you are going to
use a different server / service we
decided to put everything in the same so
we have the server is the same but they
will be connected multiple different
tasks so each task will have the its own
cue
yeah I mean you basically have your
service because that's the thing like
the do actually work is being done on
the workers so this the queue system the
server of the where the client connects
it's just kind of a way off of this like
in like sending data to whatever it
needs to be processed oh you compare
gear man to another another message
queuing system such as zeromq sorry that
with the echo effect it worse oh I like
a message like storm oh that's what for
example it's it seemed it's very similar
that's you know like celery so when I
mention like how it work celery is
basically that celery uses rabbitmq or
already seen the backbone and it's only
the actually the communication protocol
so it's just you have a client that will
send the data to a to message partial
system and have workers so it's exactly
the same so the difference being that
gierman does not require more like a
radius on the side it does everything by
itself like readies itself is building C
but the principle is the same further
questions not the case okay thanks again
Pedro
you